the One Piece manga just confirmed the
shocking end of the conflict on Pirate
Island where Monkey D GARP Was Defeated
and most likely captured by the
Blackbeard Pirates which is absolutely
game changing for the story because this
will surely lead to some World altering
events that could involve the Marines
cross Guild the straw hats and even the
secret ruler of the world's emu and
that's not the only thing that happened
in this chapter because Kobe also
revealed what could be the future
justice system of the Marines plus he
finally demonstrated his incredible new
Strength for the very first time and to
top it all off we finally seem to be
heading back to Egghead island in the
very near future where we will finally
see the events that will shock the world
but honestly whatever twists are waiting
for us on ekit island it is going to be
very hard to live up to the insanity of
the hero of the Marines being defeated
because back in chapter 1071 when GARP
first announced that he was going to
save Kobe I don't think anyone seriously
thought that he would lose and be
captured like this because in this
chapter GARP nearly takes out the islet
man Pizarro all by himself and shows off
his impressive speed that even surpasses
the former Admiral kuzan but he
eventually does get surrounded by the
Blackbeard Pirates Kobe and the others
have made it safely to the Escape ship
which we'll discuss more in just a
moment and even though Kobe desperately
wants to return to help garpis already
being frozen by kuzan just like what
happened to Saul back in chapter 397
back on O'Hara which might be some good
foreshadowing here and now you might be
saying hey Manu one piece has so much
epic action going on everywhere how how
can I experience that too to which I say
worry not my child because War Thunder
is here to scratch exactly that itch for
you which is now available on PC
PlayStation and Xbox this game brings
you the ultimate all-encompassing
vehicle combat experience ever with more
than 2 000 tanks planes helicopters and
yes of course even ships from over 10
Nations to face off in Epic online
player versus player battles on maps
spending the entire globe in fact my
favorite map is actually the jungle
because there are only a few camping
spots and a lot of Close Quarter combats
also while they're Vehicles spanning
over 100 Years of technological
developments the only one true weapon
that we anime fans really need is this
Japanese anime themed ah1s helicopter
which funnily enough is called kizarazu
in other words exactly the type of
weapon that kizalu here would want to
use as a pirate in fact you can download
even more community-made anime skins if
you ever get bored with the look of your
tank and they all can also be upgraded
to an insane level with additional
equipment and armor and if you need even
more moral support in the midst of the
battle do not worry my friend because
the new daki makura pillow is there to
assist you and to get this dakimakura
pillow and other awesome bonuses
download War Thunder for free using the
link in the description trust me you
will not want to miss this but before we
go any further into what this could
possibly mean for garb's future let's
first talk about what this means for
kuzan and even though at this point you
might say that it's just major copium
from my end but I'm still not convinced
that kuzan is evil because maybe the
Iceman knew that Garb was going to die
from his dab wound in the last chapter
so freezing him was a way to keep him
alive while his body heals you know kind
of like going into cryo-freeze plus I'm
pretty sure that the rest of the black
Bay Pirates would have kept stabbing and
shooting GARP until they knew that he
was dead for sure but if he is Frozen
then it makes sense that they have
stopped and it's also a major convenient
way to keep GARP trapped at the same
time although we've seen characters
break out of the ice before just saying
doflamingo for instance Bobby before we
get back to garb's future there is one
other mind-blowing point I want to make
about what all of this means for aokiji
because if you look at the title of that
chapter it is named the last lesson so
I'm kind of wondering if this scene
where GARP sacrifices himself to save
Kobe is actually the so-called last
lesson that Garb is trying to teach to
kuzan because if GARP is willing to give
up his own life to protect the person
that he most believes in then maybe
kuzan is being set up to do the very
same thing in the future and if we are
thinking along these lines then the
person that makes the most sense for him
to sacrifice himself or would definitely
be Robin That's because as we pointed
out in the last chapter kuzan basically
lets her live after the destruction of
ahara and then ever since has been
waiting to see what type of person she
will turn out to be in other words could
we see him give up his own life to save
Robin during the inevitable fight
between Blackbeard's crew and the straw
hats well only time will tell but
whatever future role is in the story I
think it's fair to say that we all
thought that garp's role would be a
whole lot different than what we see at
the end of this chapter here I mean he
is the hero of the Marines and many
consider him to be actually the
strongest Marine at least in his prime
plus on top of that he is Luffy's
grandfather which means that he should
have some major role left to play in the
story which could still turn out to be
the case just not quite the way that we
were expecting it to and also what we
covered last week's chapter we
speculated on exactly what could happen
in the future if GARP was indeed
captured and to sum it up here there are
essentially three options for what the
blackby Pirates could do with GARP first
they could straight up kill him I mean
since kuzan though took the trouble to
freeze him that doesn't seem as likely
at this point also the narrator doesn't
say that GARP is dead it just says that
his fate is unknown so that also goes
strongly against him being dead now the
second option was for the Blackbeard
Pirates to hand GARP over to draw skills
to set up a sort of reverse Marine Fort
Arc where basically now it was Pirates
executing a marine and the third option
was for Blackbeard to try to Ransom GARP
to the world government in exchange for
being recognized as an official Kingdom
which was his original plan with Kobe
now honestly at this point I do not
really think that any of these three
outcomes have changed much but since
it's now confirmed that GARP has been
defeated let's dive a little bit deeper
into how each of these options could
play out and why they would make a lot
of sense for the story as I just said
the option that I still think is the way
most unlikely one is Garb straight up
dying right now I mean the only real
purpose that would serve is to inspire
Luffy to get revenge and for Kobe to
inherit garb's will of being a great
honest Marine which just doesn't seem
epic enough for a character like GARP at
this point especially since Luffy isn't
even here but that's of course nowhere
near exciting as if GARP gets turned
over to cross Guild foreign execution
and with a 3 billion Barry bouncy I kind
of wonder how the leaders of cross Guild
would even pay that amount of money but
let's just assume they do get their
hands on GARP then we could be in for a
global broadcast execution on the same
scale as Marine Forts and I'm pretty
sure that garb's Marine friends would
absolutely come to save them unless they
were ordered not to which might cause
even more Marines to resign if that were
to happen and I'd also expect Luffy to
come to save his grandfather and on top
of that Shanks could also be showing up
as well which would have actually
disastrous consequences which we'll
discuss in just a moment but honestly
though I don't think that Oda would have
another execution style Epic War just
for the sake of it so let's analyze some
of the reasons that Marine for it was so
impactful for the story well first of
all before the war even started the
darkness fruit users snuck into imple
down and recruited some of the most
powerful prisoners onto his crew in
other words if we are having another
kind of War like Marine Fort I wonder if
Blackbeard would try to do something
similar instead another prisoner out of
imple down and if you're wondering who
that might be well look no further than
this pink guy right here no no no no
this one yes that's right you may have
forgotten that though Flamingo is
actually still in jail but he is and
more importantly he knows some of the
world government's most important and
deepest secrets in particular the
National Treasure of marijua which still
hasn't been confirmed exactly what it
even is and that is exactly the type of
information I think that I'm sure
Blackbeard would love to get his hands
on which does bring us to the next
important aspect of marineford which was
that the person being executed had
someone very special to them tried to
rescue them and that special person
which was Whitebeard ended up dying but
what's important about the former
yonko's death was that it was all part
of Blackbeard's plot to steal a second
devil fruit in other words even if we
had a second Marine Fort style war even
if it was on a smaller scale than the
first one this could be another
opportunity Unity for Blackbeard to
Swope in and steal another super
powerful devil fruit if you know what I
mean maybe Luffy's fruit sengoku's
Buddha fruit or even one of the Admiral
Powers might make sense here or if it
wasn't a devil fruit that Blackbeard is
after maybe he could be coming to steal
poniglyph copies during the chaos of the
fighting and if we focus more on White
Bear dying the final thing I could see
possibly happening in this scenario is
that Blackbeard takes advantage of the
fighting to finally have his
long-awaited Showdown with Shanks that's
because admarine Ford Shanks offered to
fight blackbeards but the darkness fruit
user said that this wasn't the right
time for them to fight so what better
opportunity to finally have this epic
Clash than at a reverse Marine Forts and
if they should fight I would certainly
be sweating that Shanks could die in the
scenario because I mean we all know that
Blackbeard is bound to be one of Luffy's
in-game villains so he probably won't be
defeated by anyone other than Luffy
which does Spode very badly for Shanks
who already has a pretty bad death flag
on his head and honestly that's not even
the most insane thing that could happen
in such a scenario so make sure you're
subscribed to stay up to date with
anything one piece related and I say
that because if Blackbeard doesn't hand
Garb over two cross guilds then the
other likely option is that he tries to
Ransom the hero of the Marines in
exchange for pirate Islands being
officially recognized at part of the
world governments which of course would
mean that Blackbeard would become king
which if I'm being honest it is entirely
possible that the world government would
simply refuse this and not give
Blackbeard what he wants but let's
assume for a minute that they do agree
and Blackbeard becomes an official king
of the world governments and uh I'm
warning you right now strap on your seat
belts because if this happens it could
change everything that we know about the
final war at the end of the story and so
to set this up let's head back to
chapter 907 where we're first introduced
to the empty throne in marijua here we
can see that this annoying guy right
here here is making his oath as the new
king of the Goa Kingdom and to do this
he's supposed to place a blade before
the empty throne and swear to not try
and see control over other kingdoms now
honestly of course no one really cares
about Stelly but this is important to
think about if we're actually
considering Blackbeard possibly becoming
an official king of the world
governments because it's very reasonable
to assume that Blackbeard would also be
required to come in and make this oath
before the empty Throne now of course
Blackbeard would probably never keep
that promise but the key point is that
Blackbeard would supposedly have access
to marijua and man my mind is just going
crazy when thinking about Blackbeard
just strolling around the Holy Land
because who is to say that Blackbeard
doesn't already know about some of the
secrets hidden up there on the top of
the red line could he already know about
emu possible or is there some other
secret like a devil fruit tree that he
might be very interested in honestly
there are so many possibilities in the
scenario and Blackbeard's so desperately
wanting to join the world government is
very sus in my opinion but if all of
this does happen and Blackbeard finds
himself in the castle then I could see
something happen that could completely
change the entire story and that's
because in chapter
1085 we were first shown the gurusi and
emu's powers and while these Powers were
still kind of kept in Silhouettes many
people have also speculated that emu
really does have some sort of powers
relating to Darkness Shadow or
nightmares and so I'm really super
curious how these Powers would fare
against Blackbeard's actual Darkness
devil food Powers I mean for instance
could Black Beard's Darkness devil fruit
negate Imus and the gorose's abilities
and if they fight then the outcome could
shake and change the entire world I mean
can you imagine if Blackbeard somehow
took out emu and the gorosei and that
way became the final villain which I
totally admit does sound kind of crazy
but just think about it for a moment
here I mean one thing that has always
been strange to me about the end game of
one piece is that there are basically
two final boss type characters so far
Blackbeard and emu and I guess Akino but
let's not count let's not get into that
and if we assume that Luffy is supposed
to fight Blackbeard for the one piece
then does he go and fight emo afterwards
or does emu come to love tail or does
Luffy and Blackbeard team up to fight
emu that honestly has always seemed kind
of weird because obviously finding the
one piece has always seemed like the
obvious climax to the story so wouldn't
it make sense if those two Final Bosses
fought each other first and only one
emerged as the final super villain wow I
didn't expect that we go that deep into
Theory territory in this video and you
might think I'm crazy for speculating
all of this based on the simple fact of
GARP being captured but we've already
seen how much a single event like this
can change one piece I mean just look
back at not guard but Ace being captured
by the Blackbeard Pirates and all the my
mind-boggling Madness that that resulted
in but since we've talked so much Theory
stuff right now there are still a few
other super interesting points from this
chapter that hint at the end game
outcome for one piece and the first is
that we've seen Kobe finally unleash a
truly impressive attack which is called
honesty impact basically we see Kobe
with a hockey covered fist which might
be conquerors hockey by the way that
very much resembles garp's devastatingly
powerful Galaxy impact that we just saw
in chapter 1080 and he completely
destroys the giant hand that is about to
crush the escaping marine Vessel clearly
Kobe has learned a thing or two from
Garb but what I'm most interested in is
the honesty part of the attack name
because I think this could be important
for shadowing for the type of justice
that Kobe will Embrace when he
eventually becomes an admiral of the
Marines honest Justice because I mean it
goes along with his character and it's a
stark contrast to the corruption that
exists in the current world government
and the Marine I mean to be honest the
world government is actually incredibly
dishonest in many situations especially
when they try to cover up the horrible
events in Alabaster Andres Rosa and
O'Hara and Alice just goes on and on in
other words I'm definitely looking
forward for some change of philosophy
that Kobe will hopefully bring to the
Marines in the future plus we finally
get to see more of why exactly guard
believes so much in Kobe and that's
because we get to see many of the
interactions during Kobe's time training
with Garb and see just how hard he had
to work to become as strong as he is but
that's not the only impressive thing
that he does because we also get to see
exactly how Kobe ended up captured by
Blackbeard basically in chapter 1059 we
saw the start of this conflict on Amazon
Lily where Blackbeard attacked with the
hope of taking the pirate Emperor's boa
Hancock's devil fruit and while the
yonko was stopped by a combination of
Kobe the seraphim and Silva's Rayleigh
it does turn out that Blackbeard was
going to take hundreds of Marines with
his as prisoners that was at least until
Kobe offered to trade himself in for all
of those Marines which is how he ended
up being captured in the first place and
if that's not what you call being a hero
then I don't know what is so it does
make even more sense now why GARP has so
much faith in Kobe but moving a little
bit more along in the chapter we get a
narrator box which explains that
tomorrow's newspaper has information
that Kobe was safe GARP disappeared on
Pirate Island and apparently that Luffy
is going to claim eckhead Island as his
own territory now we do have to keep in
mind that this is the newspaper which
usually does exaggerate and twist things
but regardless it seems that we finally
shift back to eckat Island we even get
to see that the ships carrying sent
Saturn and Admiral kizaru are finally
pulling up to the islands and so after
nine whole chapters away we're finally
going to return for the conclusion of
this Arc that we were literally told
Will shock the entire world and uh I'm
I'm so excited to see the strides again
in particular her they're inevitable
encountered with Saint Saturn and an
admiral and after seeing a bit of what
his powers might be doing in chapter
1085 I simply cannot wait to see him and
kizeru in action against Luffy however
we still have to remember that they are
not the only people here because we also
know that someone from Blackbeard's crew
is here as well which brings us back to
the question of what they could also be
doing here and one idea that I saw on
Twitter posted by the user threescal Joe
was that Blackbeard could be bringing
big mom's daughter pudding to try and
use her devil fruit powers to get some
top secret information out of vegapunk I
did really like that idea so shout out
to him and in case you forgot pudding
has the memory devil fruit power which
lets her see and manipulate a person's
memories so if pudding is forced to use
her powers on the genius scientists I do
wonder what type of information he could
be after either plans for some
incredibly powerful technology secrets
about the void Century or how to read
the pony glyphs or maybe something
related to devil fruits but even if this
specific scenario wasn't the case
Blackbeard might be able to use pudding
on the newly captured Garb to retrieve
some memories from the hero of the
Marines and what memory specifically
might Blackbeard be after in this case
well how about information about the
person who inspired Blackbeard the most
rocks these are back after all GARP was
the one who defeated rocks with the help
of Roger so he is sure to know a lot of
valuable information about this Infamous
pirate from over 40 years ago and uh
hold on if if this were to happen then
does that mean that we could actually
get a real flashback to the events of
God Valley I mean if I'm being honest I
have been dying to see the legendary
clash between Roger Garb and Rox and the
manga which I bet would undoubtedly be
one of the most hype moments in the
entire story and if all of this has
gotten you to want a pure injection of
the most badass moments in the entire
story then you can check out my ranking
of the most exciting moments in all of
One Piece right here thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next one